в Україні тривають процеси подолання
комуністичної чи російсько-імперської
спадщини їх актуальність стала ще більш
відчутною після початку повномасштабної
війни адже саме решта цієї спадщини
Росія використовує для доведення однієї
з ключових Тез своєї пропаганди теза яка
є основою цієї війни про те що нібито
українські росіяни в один народ і так
немає потреби існування окремої
Української держави дуже важливо що ці
процеси продовжуються тепер і за
декомунізацію почався декомунізація
важливо що ці процеси зачепили один з
ключових російських імперських та
советских міфів про так звану Велику
Вітчизняну війну мова йде про те що з
пам'ятники меморіалів які присвячені
Другій світовій війні мають бути
вилучені і демонтовані комуністичні
символи та написи позбудемося від
російського імперського штампу в
советского штампу Велика Вітчизняна
війна від неправильної хронології цієї
війни Я впевнений що це ще один
наступний важливий крок рухаємося далі
Слава Україні